A rude Hollywood screenwriter.
A man undone by his high school sweetheart.
A small role on The Big Bang Theory?!
Lance Barber has played a ton of roles beyond
"Young Sheldon" — keep watching to learn
more.
One of the most prominent running gags in
"The Big Bang Theory" involved Sheldon telling
stories about his childhood in Texas.
Sheldon's stories portrayed a group of dysfunctional
countrified southerners.
They couldn't be more different than the timid
and analytical Sheldon.
However, fans have now gotten a firsthand
perspective of Sheldon's family with the spin-off
series "Young Sheldon."
Sheldon sometimes described his father as
a crazed drunk who used his wife's favorite
cookware for shooting practice.
However, "Young Sheldon" portrays him as a
simple, blue-collar football coach who does
his best for his family even if he makes mistakes.
The two versions of George Cooper Sr. don't
always line up, but neither one is strictly
bad.
Actor Lance Barber makes the most out of playing
George on "Young Sheldon."
However, George Cooper is far from Barber's
only role.
Throughout his career, he has played a number
of other characters that may make George Cooper
Sr. from "Young Sheldon" look familiar.
Lance Barber has no delusions about his level
of fame.
Barber has been a career actor for over 20
years but has rarely held the spotlight.
Instead, Barber has made his living playing
a series of smaller roles.
His earliest role was as a man in a coma on
"ER."
Later roles included parts in "Yes, Dear",
"What I Like About You," and "Come to Papa."
In 2014, Barber told the "Battle Creek Enquirer":
"I was a character guy, I was heavy, I was
likable, I guess.
So I had the opportunity to play best friend
guy to the lead guy."
Despite his lack of mainstream notoriety,
he still loves being an actor:
"I feel very lucky.
As an actor we all want more work, and more
quality work.
But I have zero complaints."
Being Sheldon's dad isn't Barber's only recognizable
performance.
Years before "The Big Bang Theory" debuted,
Barber landed a recurring spot in one of HBO's
most underrated series, "The Comeback".
The show was about an aging sitcom actress
named Valerie Cherish.
Valerie allows a film crew to document her
return to show business.
Like "The Office" and "Arrested Development,"
"The Comeback" reveled in creating awkward
moments between its characters.
On the show, Lance Barber played the role
of Paulie G., the showrunner of Valerie's
latest sitcom gig, "Room and Bored."
The two maintain an ongoing feud throughout
"The Comeback" and remain enemies even after
the fictional sitcom is canceled.
Unfortunately, unlike "The Office," it never
reached a high degree of mainstream popularity.
The show was canceled after just one season.
That is, until "The Comeback" made a comeback.
Over the years, the series had garnered a
cult following on the Internet.
In 2014, the show was revived for a second
season, reintroducing the main characters
nine years later.
In an interview with Bustle, Barber called
the show's return "a dream come true."
This time, Paulie G. is different.
When we meet him in 2014, he's gotten clean
following his addiction to heroin during the
events of Season 1.
He seems much more willing to work with Valerie
instead of against her, though it isn't long
before new tensions arise in their relationship.
Aside from "The Comeback," the latter half
of the 2000s saw primarily bit roles for Lance
Barber.
He had one-episode appearances in a variety
of shows, including "Joey," "The Mentalist,"
"Monk," and "CSI: Miami".
In the 2010s, he showed up in even more series,
like "Grey's Anatomy," "Key and Peele," "How
I Met Your Mother," "Bob's Burgers," "Brooklyn
Nine-Nine," and "Black-ish", and "Faking It".
His most recognizable role during this time,
however, was as Bill Ponderosa in "It's Always
Sunny in Philadelphia."
Like most characters in the series, Bill Ponderosa
is a certifiable scumbag:
"Diddly Dee - miss me?
Don't answer that.
Alright."
Although Dee once had a crush on him in high
school, he's a hedonistic narcissist in the
present day.
He cheats on his wife, abuses his kids, and
is addicted to practically everything under
the sun.
He also briefly becomes Dennis' brother-in-law
after Dennis marries and then divorces his
sister, Maureen.
Bill was last seen in Season 13, where he's
invited by Frank to attend the Super Bowl.
So, why would Barber look so familiar to "Big
Bang Theory" fans?
Long before "Young Sheldon" was announced,
Lance Barber actually had a one-time appearance
on "The Big Bang Theory" as a different character.
Whenever you see George Cooper Sr. being a
well-meaning dad on "Young Sheldon," you're
also looking at Leonard's high school bully,
Jimmy Speckerman.
Speckerman shows up in 2011's "The Speckerman
Recurrence," which focuses on Speckerman's
failed attempts to make amends with Leonard:
"Holy crap, man, it's good to see you!"
However, Speckerman doesn't actually have
good intentions.
He only apologizes to Leonard while drunk,
and then denies his actions the next day.
Sheldon helps his friend Leonard stand up
to the bully.
He never seems to notice that Speckerman looks
just like his father.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
TV shows are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.